الماء
هو مورد لا يمكننا العيش بدون
وجود كمية هائلة من
المياه في
كل مبنى وهذه المصفوفة المعقدة
التي تعيش داخل
جدراننا توصلها إلى حيث نحتاجها ، فهي تحتوي على
أنابيب مياه مبردة لتكييف الهواء ،
إنها تحتوي على المياه المنزلية التي نوفرها
اشرب واستخدمها في الحمامات
أه تحتوي على رشاشات
ماء ساخن للري
ولكن أصغر التسريبات على طول أي من
هذه الخطوط يمكن أن تسبب الكثير من الضرر
حتى قبل تشييد المبنى بالكامل
وهذه مشكلة تواجهها إحدى
أكبر الشركات العقارية في إسرائيل  واجهنا
منذ حوالي 15 عامًا ، شرع تادار في
برنامج
للنظر في جميع النفايات التي لدينا في
جميع مناطق البناء لدينا
وأحد الأشياء التي لاحظناها هو أن
لدينا الكثير من تسرب المياه
والكثير من المياه  الضرر
وأدركنا أنه يتعين علينا القيام بشيء حيال هذا ،
أدخل الرياح عداد المياه ai في
مهمة لإيقاف
التسربات عند المصدر ، فالرياح تعني
استخبارات المياه
وما تفعله الرياح  التعرف
على تدفق المياه عبر الأنابيب ، فهو يعرف
كيف يتعلم ما هو طبيعي للموقع
، وبعد ذلك عندما يرى الشذوذ ، يمكنه
تنبيه أو إغلاق المياه ويمنع
التسرب من الحدوث أبدًا
ابتكره مهندسون إسرائيليون في عام 2012
حيث يمكن دمج التكنولوجيا في
القائمة  البنية التحتية تم
بالفعل
تنبيه النظام وتحديد التسريبات الخاصة به أو
يمكن وضعه أثناء البناء
كما هو الحال هنا في wix hq الجديد في تل أبيب
بحيث يستخدم عملاؤنا التجاريون مثل wix
أو Microsoft المنتج
ويراقب تدفق المياه في تلك
المواقع
و  قد يتخذ قرارًا بإغلاق المياه
تلقائيًا إذا كان يعتقد أن
الضرر قد يحدث
وفقًا لاتحاد شركات التأمين البريطانية ،
يعد الضرر الناجم عن المياه أحد أكثر
مطالبات الملكية شيوعًا في المملكة
المتحدة وفي المتوسط يمكن أن تكلف مطالبة انفجار الأنابيب ما
قرب من 9000 جن
ه إسترليني  إنه لأمر مدهش حقًا مقدار
الضرر الذي يمكن أن تسببه المياه في
المبنى ، حيث تتكسر الفطيرة في الطابق العشرين
وتتدفق المياه إلى أسفل
وأي شيء في أعقابه يتم تدميره حقًا
بخلاف تكلفة الإصلاحات المادية ،
يمكن أن يكلفك التسرب البطيء الأصغر حجمًا ثلاثة ملليمترات
في الأنبوب يمكن أن يهدر حوالي 946 لترًا من
الماء يوميًا
وفقًا لمصادر المياه الأمريكية
حوالي 25 بالمائة من المياه التي تدخل في
يتم إهدار أي مبنى بسبب
أشياء صغيرة جدًا في منع الضرر
والادخار المالي بعيدًا ،
ربما يكون الدور الأكثر أهمية الذي
يقول ديسيان أن الرياح تريد أن تلعبه هو الحفاظ على
هذا المورد الثمين
في مواجهة صناعة الإمداد العالمية المتضائلة
بنسبة عشرين بالمائة من استهلاك المياه في العالم
إذا كنا  يمكن أن يوفر عشرة في المائة من ذلك
وهو توفير اثنين في المائة من المياه في العالم ،
عميل واحد حريص على تقليل هدر المياه
هو
خطوط إنتاج بيبسي للأغذية والمشروبات
بشكل عام تستخدم الكثير من المياه
في بيبسيكو ، والهدف الوحيد هو
أه تحديد النفايات التي نستخدمها  الريح اليوم
في خطوط رقائق البطاطس لدينا
يتم غسل كل شريحة من البطاطس
قبل أن نجعلها تتحول إلى رقاقة بطاطس
مع الريح  لقد ساعدتنا
التكنولوجيا على أن نكون فعالين حقًا في استخدام المياه لدينا ، فقد حققنا 10 وفورات في استهلاك المياه مقارنةً بالرياح الأساسية لعام 2019 التي لا تخلو من المنافسة نظرًا لأن المزيد من حلول توفير المياه عالية التقنية تأتي
عبر الإنترنت ،
لكن الطبيب يقول إن الشركة التي تتخذ من إسرائيل مقراً
لها تكتسب جمهورًا عالميًا.
أكبر الأسواق هي الولايات
المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة وبقية أوروبا ، لذا فإن
الذكاء الاصطناعي يحل بعضًا من أكثر
مشاكل العالم تعقيدًا والتي لا يمكن
حلها قبل أن تعرف أن ندرة المياه
هنا مشكلة تجارية
ضخمة تسبب أضرارًا جسيمة
وحلًا يديرها  حل
كلاهما المثير بالنسبة لي